et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
christophe béchu bonjour monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup je voulais être
avec nos mises la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour bonjour monsieur le ministre on
va évidemment commencé en parlant de la
conférence de presse d'elisabeth borgne
1 sur la question de l'énergie le
bouclier tarifaire qui a donc été revu
15% d'augmentation de hausse de
l'électricité et du gaz pour l'année
prochaine pour les français ce que vous
assumez de dire aux français qu'ils
doivent contribuer ou aussi à
l'augmentation de ses prix de l'énergie
bien sûr pour pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que c'est pas le le
gouvernement qui fixe les prix on est
dans un contexte aujourd'hui où la
décision du gouvernement c'est de
limiter la hausse c'est pas de la
provoquer et dans un contexte où nous
serons le pays d'europe dans lequel le
bouclier tarifaire sera le plus
puissance avec des difficultés que ça
soulève sur le plan des finances
publiques mais là où la facture des
allemands des hollandais des anglais a
été multiplié par deux ou par trois la
hausse va être limité à 15% et avec pour
les 40% de français les plus modestes un
chèque énergie qui va permettre de
couvrir tout ou partie dans cette
censure passant par un foyer
traditionnel ça peut représenter de
presque 300 400 pensant être 400 euros /
/ / une année c'est un effort quand même
conséquent que vous demandez aux
français l'effort moyens il sera entre
20 et 25 euros selon par mois par mois
selon la manière dont vous chauffer
en clair un peu plus si c'est avec du
gaz ont peu moins si c'est avec de
l'électricité et du gaz c'est un effort
conséquent mais dans un contexte où il
faut bien comprendre que les prix ont
été multipliés par 5 ou par 10 et que
l'argent qui est mis dans le bouclier
tarifaire il représente aussi un effort
que la volonté de le couvrir pour les
40% de français les plus modestes avec
200 euros pour les 20% les plus modestes
et 100 euros pour les 20 % suivant c'est
à la fois de la solidarité de la
responsabilité de la responsabilité
parce que des prix de l'énergie est
levée ça témoigne aussi du défi lié au
réchauffement climatique que nous avons
pour sortir d'un certain nombre
d'énergies fossiles
et dont on voit aussi les tendances en
termes de prix et je pense au gaz en
disant ça vous le dites ya ce chèque
énergie qui tient compte des revenus des
français sauf qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
besoins de chauffage à lille chez julien
ou ajaccio chez moi est ce que vous
allez tenir compte des différences
territoriales est ce qu'il faut aussi
inepte territorialisée pour les français
le dispositif national il est national
et dans un contexte où à côté de ça si
vous commencez entrée sous ce type de
subtilité vous avez une hétérogénéité
dans lé niveau d'isolation du parc il
n'y a pas que le climat de l'endroit
dans lequel vous vivez la priorité c'est
évidemment de faire face à divers
exceptionnel qu'on connaît pour plein de
raisons mais c'est surtout
d'amplifier un mouvement de rénovation
des bâtiments privés et publics pour
diminuer globalement les factures tout
en améliorant notre bilan du temps ça
prend énormément vous défaite sévère pas
d'être territorialisées ce que je dis
c'est que
l'argument de ça prend du temps il est
le meilleur pour repousser et pour
attendre et qu'il faut au contraire
profité de la crise au moment où la
sensibilisation est maximale pour que
tout le monde se disent que l'argent
qu'on met dans l'isolation et dans la
rénovation y produit des effets c'est le
même argument que ceux qui disent il
faut pas investir dans le nucléaire
parce que ça prend du temps mais est ce
que ça veut dire qu'elles vont est
unique dans tout le temps dans le cours
et ce qu'il me faut pas justement
prendre des décisions rapides pour
accélérer cette rénovation thermique des
bâtiments je vous le confirme et donc
qu'est-ce que vous décidez et donc
l'automne sera l'occasion dans le cadre
de la planification écologique de ce que
nous allons présenter de pouvoir aux
côtés du dispositif qui concerne les
particuliers avec ma prime rennais
prennent of je vous rappelle que c'est
plus de deux milliards et demi d'euros
cette année qui sont consacrés pour
accompagner la rénovation thermique de
plus de 700 mille logements nous avons
le pendant en ce qui concerne les
bâtiments publics pour lequel nous
aurons à présenter un dispositif dans
les prochaines semaines avec une idée
simple il y à 500 millions de mètres
carrés public et pour ses 500 millions
de mètres carrés public là il ya là
aussi les problématiques de factures des
problématiques de passoire des
problématiques de rénovation sur lequel
on aura l'occasion de et donc fait quoi
le président français avait envisagé je
serai hyper heureux de venir le
présenter au public ses heures à caen où
l'on rendra public dans le courant de
l'automne
ça va jusqu'à fin décembre donc il vous
a pas échappé qu'on s'apprête à voter le
9 d'abord à voter le plf et ensuite
aplani j'ai justement la trajectoire
écologique de notre pays avec toute une
série de groupes de travail pour
lesquels l'enjeu sera pas de rappeler
qu'elle les diagnostics la réalité du
réchauffement mais bien tout de suite de
présenter des solutions et les mettre en
oeuvre et c'est dans ce contexte qu'on
aura l'occasion d'avancer sur ce sujet
sans tarder
oui alors c'est certainement mairie
comme come dine je prêche pour ma
paroisse ont engagé un vaste plan de
sobriété en réduisant la température des
piscines des bâtiments publics en
éteignant l'éclairage des monuments on
l'a vu à paris avec eux l'idée d'étendre
la tour eiffel est ce qu'on doit
généraliser ces mesures quitte même à
contraindre les villes à effectuer ce
genre de plan de sobriété
l'engagement qui est attendu par le
gouvernement c'est 10% d'économies
d'énergie et je précise que
cette cette philosophie cette manière de
voir les choses elle ne vaut pas que
pour l'hiver qui arrive elle vaut tout
de suite pour l'hiver qui arrive parce
qu'on a ces inquiétudes par rapport au
niveau tarif mais c'est quelque chose
auquel il faut également qu'on s'habitue
parce que la sobriété c'est le moyen de
diminuer notre empreinte carbone et donc
c'est le moyen d'atténuer le
réchauffement climatique et nous y
adapter quand j'ai dit ça que les
communes et une liberté sur la manière
de parvenir à cet objectif ça me semble
souhaitable parce qu'il peut y avoir des
particularités locales qui conduisent à
à voir par exemple investi dans des
bâtiments pour lesquelles on a assuré un
raccordement du chauffage bois et donc
pour lesquels on n'a absolument pas la
même empreinte ou les mêmes conséquences
et là aussi tout ce qui relève de
l'investissement pour accompagner le
changement climatique il est préférable
au fermeture sèche qui sont uniquement
liés à une problématique budgétaire mais
il faudra qu'on joue sur les deux qu'on
éclaire pas toutes nos villes la nuit
alors qu'il a personne dans les rues ça
ressemble à quelque chose d'assez
logique et pour vous donner un exemple
en juin nous avons initié il ya deux ans
et demi la transformation des 30000
candélabres de l'agglomération pour les
passer au led ces 70% d'économie
d'énergie et dans beaucoup de rues nous
ajoutons à ces dispositifs des
détecteurs de présence pour faire en
sorte exactement comme un particulier le
fait sur son palier des teintes quand
ces personnes bruno le maire a dit hier
devant les députés que toutes les
collectivités ne vous ne pouvait pas
être aidées par l'état de la même façon
et lui suggère de conditionner l'aide à
la rigueur budgétaire dans la gestion de
ces collectivités vous êtes d'accord
avec cette méthode d'abord c'est
l'occasion pour moi de rappeler que plus
de la moitié des communes de ce pays
sont couvertes par le bouclier tarifaire
qui a été évoquée hier puisque toutes
les communes qui ont moins de 2 millions
budget bénéficient des tarifs
réglementés et je pense que c'est
important a rappelé quand on discute de
ses sujets ensuite c'est à vocation est
très large et ça j'espère donc ça peut
concerner d'autres communes à la minute
où ça va rester sur les petites communes
uniquement à la minute où on se parle
c'est le dispositif qui existe depuis
des années qu'ils seront bien dans l'eau
j'ai une qui seront concernés plusieurs
sans doute aux alentours de 20 milles
quand on regarde la particularité c'est
que comme c'est pas sur un nombre
d'habitants mais sur un nombre
d'employés municipaux et un niveau de
budget il peut y avoir des variations
à la mine nous parlons c'est la
continuité de la même base ensuite on a
effectivement un certain nombre de
communes pour lesquelles il ya des
problématiques qui se posent et là ça va
être l'enjeu un des enjeux du plf sur
l'accompagnement des collectivités face
à l'inflation sur la manière dont on
peut les accompagner l'idée de bruno le
maire qui consiste à dire qu'il faut
qu'on soit capable de lier vertu
budgétaire aux rigueurs budgétaires et
engagements climatiques elle correspond
de toute façon au sens de l'histoire
c'est une forme de contrainte on
je dis pas ça c'est une forme de double
engagement ce que je veux dire c'est que
si on se préoccupe uniquement de la
bonne santé financière sans se
préoccuper de la bonne santé climatiques
de notre pays de nos collectivités on
passe à côté d'un objectif c'est celui
de préserver l'habitabilité de notre
planète et des territoires sur lesquels
on se situe et c'est
là que parce que les collectivités vous
disent mais nous on a besoin des aides
de l'état pour assurer la transition
énergétique j'aime à vous l'entendre
dire c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons décidé de lancer avec la première
ministre un fond vert d'accélération
pour la transition écologique je vous
fais bien vous faites bien d'en parler
parce que vous allez dans le dans le
cher si je ne m'abuse pour promouvoir la
création de ce fonds vert qui est doté
d'1 5 milliard d'euros alors que
l'association des maires de france par
exemple s'en ressentent félicite un cri
et crie bravo mais s'étonne de ne pas
avoir été associée au travail en amont
du dispositif vous les avez oublié pas
du tout et pour être très clair on a
passé près de deux heures ensemble hier
vie comme avec la ville avait clamé cf
oui mais on avait déjà passé des gens
que ceux du fondeur le 1er septembre
c'est-à-dire 48 heures après l'annnonce
du fonds vert en leur indiquant que ce
qui était tranchée aujourd'hui c'était
le montant et qu'on attendait de leur
part qui nous suggèrent des
modifications sur la manière de faire
vous savez ces histoires d'annoncer
elles sont compliquées ce que si j'avais
d'abord annoncé aux associations d'élus
qu'on allait monter un fonds vert
j'aurais laissé la politesse au
gouvernement ensuite de faire
l'annoncent auprès de la presse sur le
fait d'expliquer qu'il est un dispositif
que tu es en gestation la houle on ne
prend personne en traître c'est que on
annonce un fond on explique qu'on
souhaite qu'ils soient souples qu'il va
être disponible pour précisément
accompagner les collectivités pour
accélérer et que dans le même temps on
souhaite associer et les parlementaires
et les associations d'élus pour définir
les règles du jeu et les domaines dans
lesquels nous pourrions aller mais quand
juste pour rentrer dans le détail 5
milliards c'est un chiffre énorme pour
chaque commune vous savez très bien sont
en train de faire leur budget les
communes convent elle toucher cet argent
selon quel mécanisme est ce que là elles
sont incapables de faire leur budget en
fonction de ce fonds l'air c'est
exactement la discussion qu'on avec les
associations d'élus ces sommes elles
seront votés dans le cadre du plf elles
seront donc disponibles pour les en 2023
on veut un mécanisme qui soit
suffisamment souple pour que vous
mettiez pas six mois a déposé un dossier
pour ensuite toucher les crédits sur
l'année qui suit donc faire on a d'ores
et déjà écarté le dispositif des appels
à projets pardon d'être un peu nick pour
regarder par rapport aux dotations qui
sont les plus souples est-ce que c'est
s'appuyer sur la d6 il sur la d6 relance
sur les commissions des deux terres
mais si vous voulez le sort il faut
l'être ce que je sais c'est qu'on
regarde avec les collectivités quels
sont les dispositifs ces dernières
années qui ont été les plus souples et
c'est sans doute dans le cadre du plan
de relance qu'on a les meilleurs
exemples et vous dites oh combien les
budgets en toute connaissance de cause
elles pourront bénéficier de ces crédits
dès l'année 2000 un train alors elles
sont très contentes les les communes
cela dit elle pointe que quand même une
chose c'est que y'a aucune réponse à
l'urgence du moment c'est à dire
l'augmentation de leurs de leurs
factures et des matières premières pour
les collectivités qu'est ce que vous
comptez leur apporter comme réponse là
dessus je pense que c'est un c'est un
mauvais procès qui est encore des
inquiétudes c'est légitime et je le
comprends dans le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes mais pour cette année ses
560 millions d'euros de compléments de
crédit qui ont été ajoutés depuis le 1er
janvier dans le cadre de la loi de
finances rectificative c'est la baisse
drastique de ce qu'on appelle la taxe
intérieure sur la consommation finale
d'électricité qui correspond à 400
millions d'euros de factures
d'électricité en moins répartis entre
hearts re toutes les collectivités de ce
pays et ses dispositifs la salir près
d'un milliard d'euros c'est pour l'année
2022 dans le cadre de l'année 2023 vous
avez des hétérogénéités de situations en
fonction des collectivités les régions
qui bénéficie d'une fraction de la tva
bénéficier indirectement aussi de la
progression des prix puisque la tva
évidemment liée à la progression de ses
prix la situation des départements elle
est contrastée dans le pays mais il vous
a pas échappé que le marché immobilier
posco vide avait été particulièrement
dynamique partout sur le territoire et
avec un très bon premier semestre sur
les droits de mutation dans un contexte
où la baisse du chômage a entraîné une
diminution du nombre de bébés
donc il faut que je ne dis pas ça je dis
juste que la situation ait évolué au fur
et à mesure des mois on la regarde il
s'agit pas de crier avant d'avoir mal il
s'agit pas que willard et que ce soit
soit à des difficultés qui sont
complexes et c'est vraiment le chemin de
responsabilité et de vérité sur lequel
nous sommes avec les collectifs la mf
propose également de dinde exc la
dotation globale de fonctionnement sur
sur l'inflation est ce que vous êtes
plutôt favorable non nous n'y sommes pas
favorables
d'abord parce que c'est un dispositif
qui a été abandonné il ya plus de quinze
ans par la totalité des gouvernements il
y avait un dispositif de ce type qui à
une époque reposer sur l'inflation puis
sur une part d'inflation et sur une part
de croissance qu'à partir du moment où
on est attaché libre autonomie des
collectivités locales il faut arriver à
trouver un dispositif dans lequel on
accompagne les collectivités pour pas le
laisser seul face à des flambées de prix
mais dans lequel on n'est pas non plus
dans une logique où on aurait une
relation avec ces collectivités qui
consisterait à normes et toutes nos
relations budgétaire quand vous avez une
année avec peu d'inflation ça voudra
dire qu'il faut qu'on baisse la dgf ou
qu'on l'a juste à la baisse ou un hiver
doux considère que finalement les
dépenses qui étaient liés à des
problématiques ont pas été dépensés ça
n'a pas de sens il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver un dispositif on est dans un
temps exceptionnel parce qu'on a été
tellement habitués à des années
d'inflation basse que là on est dans une
situation particulière et même par
rapport à l'énergie vous avez une
hétérogénéité de situation des
collectivités d'une certaine taille
elles ont des contrats pluriannuels pour
certaines elles sont encore couverts par
ces contrats pluriannuels avec des prix
bas qui date de l'an dernier pour
d'autres elles se sont retrouvés cet été
au pic des difficultés avec la fin de
leur contrat des nécessités de
renégociation et donc des difficultés
d'une autre nature donc il faut qu'on
ait à la fois une vision globale de ces
sujets contexte qui est celui de
responsabilité dans les finances
publiques que nous connaissons et une
capacité à cibler les plus fragiles
celles qui se retrouvent avec des effets
de ciseaux qui sont complexes pour
pouvoir les accompagner et ne pas les
fragiliser sur la question des énergies
renouvelables un projet de loi sur le
développement de ces énergies
renouvelables et est annoncée pour quand
il sera présenté avant la fin du mois de
septembre en conseil des ministres il
commencera samedi par le monde est apte
je vous le confirme n'était pas
totalement impossible que ce soit le 26
septembre si vous voulez que jusque là
un peu plus précis mentionnés
du jour du conseil des ministres
mais la date tel ce qu'elle est projeté
ce serait le 26 septembre pour
qu'ensuite ils puissent commencer sa vie
parlementaire par la haute assemblée
manière ensuite à poil aux dents il a
admis un article ça c'est en cours de
définition avec les avis positifs qui
sont vendus mais sur les grandes baies
sur les grandes lignes la france est en
retard dans le développement des
énergies renouvelables non seulement
notre part d'énergie renouvelable est
moins importante que les engagements
qu'on a pu prendre que la part de nos
voisins mais le délai moyen pour
déployer ces énergies renouvelables et
deux à trois fois plus long que dans les
pays qui nous entourent avec des
successions de procédure qui complique
les choses et une multiplication des
recours comment on accélère ce
développement des énergies renouvelables
à la fois pour compenser une partie de
notre retard pour accélérer notre sortie
du fossile et pour participer à l'effort
de décarbonation notre économie dans le
cadre de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
c'est ce sont les grandes lignes du
projet qui va être défendus avec deux
grands types d'énergie sur lesquelles on
va accélérer le photovoltaïque et
l'éolien offshore
voilà donc ce que vous souhaitez c'est
permettre l'accélération de la mise en
oeuvre des projets avec toute la
difficulté que ça risque de poser de
créer des frictions sur le sur le
terrain
nous sommes un pays dans lequel
la passion pour le débat
et l'attachement des gens
alors territoire alors si des conduit
parfois à des frictions il faut juste
qu'on comprenne que là le sujet il
dépasse assez largement l'enjeu des
frictions c'est l'avenir de la planète
est précisément notre mix énergétique et
le montant des factures qu'on aura à
payer dans les années qui viennent donc
je veux bien qu'on ait des disputes mais
voilà des sujets en termes d'intérêt
général sur lequel on devrait tous se
retrouver au moins sur les principes
ensuite on pourra discuter tel ou tel
projet mais il ya une urgence à
accélérer sur ces sujets c'est le sens
de ce projet de loi il y aura une mesure
sur les jets privés dans un texte
d'accélération sur les énergies
renouvelables non ce sera un cavalier
budgétaire
mais sinon vous êtes favorable mais nous
aurons évidemment l'occasion dans le
cadre de l'automne dont je parlais avec
les différents sujets de discuter de
tous les modes de transport et de
l'aérien au sens large j'ai déjà dit
dans un autre contexte que prendre les
choses par le petit bout de la lorgnette
en parlant du barbecue du jet du green
du golf ça n'est pas au niveau et c'est
ferran c'est plus d'opposer les français
les uns aux autres en faisant de
l'écologie du buzz ça n'est ni ma
conception du ciel du gouvernement sur
ces sujets clément mode il me semble que
j'ai eu ce type de discussions et
clément bonne mais contrairement à ce
que certains voudraient le faire dire où
nous faire croire il n'a pas plaidé pour
une interdiction il a expliqué en
répondant à vos patrons des écologistes
qui lui semblait souhaitable de
travailler à une régulation à l'échelle
européenne plus largement ce soir
s'ouvre le congrès des régions ce sera à
vichy des présidents de région qui dans
une tribune dans le journal du dimanche
vous demande d'engager sans plus tarder
une véritable réforme de la
décentralisation que leur répondez vous
que la porte est ouverte que dans les
discussions que j'ai eues avec régions
de france au début du mois de juillet à
la fin du mois d'août
au début du mois de septembre
en particulier avec la présidente de
région de france carole delga et à
l'occasion d'une rencontre qui s'est
tenue à matignon nous leur avons demandé
de nous indiquer les sujets sur lesquels
il souhaitait qu'on travaille moi je
sais pas dire on va faire une grande loi
de décentralisation proposer des
articles et on va le faire ce que je
souhaite y compris parce que tous les
niveaux de collectivités n'ont pas
forcément la même vision de ce qui
pourrait décentralisée de quelle manière
c'est qu'on construise un agenda
territoriales c'est la méthode qui a été
proposé et qui consiste à partir du
début de l'année prochaine quand on aura
passé ce plf ce projet de loi sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables cette feuille de route sur
la planification écologique à prendre
des sujets les uns après les autres
peut-être certains uniquement avec un
bloc de collectivités d'autre avec tout
je pense au logement on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on a des choses qui sont
grippés dans le pays on a des attentes
des régions des départements des villes
où des sujets sur la possibilité pour
les saisonniers de seloger parfois sur
la place les airbnb sur les inquiétudes
sur la rénovation thermique d'une partie
des bâtiments des parquet chêne bref on
a plein de sujets sur la table
faites-moi des propositions je leur dis
donnez moi les éléments avec lequel on
construit un agenda de discussions et
négociations
vous vous donnez quand même un
calendrier pour ne faire cette nouvelle
loi le trimestre dans lequel nous somme
va servir à établir cet agenda
territoriale et ce discours on l'a tenu
aux régions nous l'avons tenu au
département d'ailleurs avec isabelle
borne avant-hier jeu les tenues aux
communes durant l'été en leur demandant
de nous faire remonter les sujets sur
lesquels il souhaitait qu'on travaille
la grande loi fourre tout dans laquelle
vous mettez plein d'articles dans
laquelle chacun s'imagine qu'il va
retrouver ses petits et à l'issue de
laquelle on peut générer une forme de
déception je pense pas que ce soit la
météo a parlé passé le canasson non mais
l'incantation à dire faisons une
décentralisation pour moi elles comptent
moins que de dire on a un sujet sur le
logement on a un sujet sur l'aménagement
on a un sujet sur la péréquation et je
pense qu'en prenant des choses de cette
manière peut-être qu'on s'apercevra
qu'il faut faire une loi mais peut-être
qu'on se rendra compte qu'avec quelques
articles quelques éléments on peut aller
vite sans entrer dans un processus
législatif complexe
qu'il n'y aura pas de baisse de 10
milliards pour eux comme ça avait été un
temps évoquée durant la campagne
présidentielle et qu'il n'y aura pas de
limitation de leurs dépenses
le projet loi de finances sera présenté
dans quelques jours à aucun moment une
baisse des dotations n'a étaient au menu
nous prévoyons assez clair avec vous je
pense c'est une clarté absolue avec
bruno le maire nous prévoyons une
progression du bloc des collectivités
locales de 24 milliards d'euros de
dépenses sur le quinquennat le message
que nous portons aux élus c'est de dire
il faut qu on modère la progression de
nos dépenses il faut pas qu on les
diminue il faut qu on modère la
progression on a un niveau de dépense
qui est parmi les plus élevés au monde
en termes de dépenses publiques dans ce
contexte il faut à la fois qu'on diminue
nos dépenses de fonctionnement par ap
l'inflation pour dégager les marges de
manoeuvre pour investir c'est l'histoire
de l'énergie
il faut on trouve les crédits pour aller
faire les investissements pour le
réchauffement climatique plutôt que de
courir après les factures de
fonctionnement qui sont liées au retard
en termes d'adaptation ou en termes
d'atténuation par rapport à je suis pas
dans mes limiter la hausse des dépenses
c'est le retour du principe des contrats
de quart avec un certain nombre de
changements notamment le fait que nous
n'imaginons pas des contrats qui soit
contraignant mais au contraire des
dispositifs de confiance avec les élus
qu'on aura l'occasion de détailler dans
ces prochains jours et ces prochaines
semaines au sujet oui sur les sur les
retraites on en parle beaucoup est ce
que vous êtes vous même favorable à
cette à ce projet de réforme des
retraites au travers du projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale je me
prononcerai pas sur les modalités
d'abord parce que c'est pas de mon champ
de compétence et du sujet que je connais
le mieux ce que je sais c'est que
l'histoire des retraites c'est d'abord
un sujet de démographie et dans un
contexte où vous avez un déséquilibre si
vous voulez éviter un jour de vous
retrouver à baisser les pensions qui
sont déjà pas un niveau extraordinaire
dans ce pays et donc si vous voulez
porter le projet présidentiel qui
consiste à relever les pensions les plus
basses et à sécuriser les générations à
venir il faudra qu'on travaille plus
longtemps qu'on le fasse au travers d'un
dispositif ou d'un autre jeu je n'ai pas
d'avis à ce stade si vous voulez sur le
meilleur chemin emprunté en revanche je
n'ai aucun doute que c'est un chemin à
emprunter et que plus nous le ferons
lite avec une mise en application dès
l'été 23 plus des effets se feront
sentir c'est une question de solidarité
avec les générations qui nous serait pas
aussi parce que vous êtes assez
secrétaire général d'horizon c'est le
mouvement des doigts philippe edouard
philippe lui disais il faut aller
jusqu'à 65 66 voix 67 est ce que vous
dites en dessous de 65 c'est une réforme
a minima ce que je dis c'est il est
urgent de faire une réforme et de
l'enclencher on parle on parle il faut
agir bon ça indique peut-être plus sûres
en effet de le passer dès la fin de
l'année edouard philippe il continue de
caracoler dans les paramètres de
de popularité en commande disait vous
aller le retrouver à fond à
fontainebleau pour les journées
d'horizon c'est toujours le mieux placé
pour prendre la relève d' emmanuel
macron je rentrerai pas là dedans y
compris parce que dans son propre état
d'esprit 2027 ses dents tellement
longtemps et et l'histoire est jalonnée
de favori
ça n'a pas de sens aujourd'hui on est en
2002 on est dans un contexte politique
économique sociale compliquée avec plein
de sujets avec beaucoup de crises à
affronter et se projeter pour réfléchir
c'est bien se projeter pour postuler ce
n'est ni le moment ni le sujet pendant
des mois j'imagine qu'il va regarder ce
qui se passe du côté des républicains
qui sont ont fonctionné livrent une
bataille pour la présidence du parti est
ce qu eric ciotti président du lr ça
serait une bonne nouvelle pour horizon
est ce que vous espérez attiré à vous et
républicains plus modérée vous savez
j'ai trop d'attachement ma propre
liberté pour vouloir contraindre celle
des autres je ne suis plus membre des
républicains je me garderai bien donc
d'aller donner des conseils aux anciens
adhérents du parti dans lequel j'étais
pour savoir faire qu'ils doivent voter
et proposer un soutien ou esquisser une
préférence
je pense que ce serait une fausse bonne
idée à tout point de vue parce qu'on
pourrait penser qu elle n'est pas dénuée
d'arrière pensées or en l'espèce je
considère que c'est vraiment aux
républicains de choisir un chef le choix
de leur chef dira quelque chose de leur
ligne ça c'est une certitude merci à
christophe boesch merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin julien
regarder une de la voix du nord des
gestes barrières pour passer l'hiver
c'est à la une de votre journal
une crise à l'autre qu est-ce qu vidéos
prises énergétique
[Musique]